are continuing to follow the news of the
passing of former nevada senator
longtime senator harry reid reid was the
longest serving senator in nevada
history when he retired back in 2017 and
our david charns joins us now with more
information well harry reid's family
telling us here at 8 news now that he
died at home from cancer today we were
told he was surrounded by family his
wife sending us this statement and it
says in part
harry died peacefully this afternoon
surrounded by our family following a
courageous four-year battle with
pancreatic cancer we are so proud of the
legacy he leaves behind both on the
national stage and his beloved nevada
harry was deeply touched to see his
decades of service to nevada honored in
recent weeks with the renaming of las
vegas
airport in his honor
harry reid was born in searchlight in
1939 he was the youngest lieutenant
governor at just 30. then he went on to
serve on the nevada gaming commission
then as a u.s rep and then senator
eventually becoming the most powerful
man in the u.s senate this was part of
his final speech as he bowed out in
2017.
during my 34 years in congress
i've seen the country change i've seen
nevada change the changes in the country
and nevada have been for the better
harry reid is our state's longest
serving senator with five decades of
service of course the airport just named
his honor fittingly placed so many first
step foot in a state that he simply
treasured so much former president
barack obama says reed's wife had asked
those close to him to send him a letter
these past few days and i'm going to
read part of this here
he the former president writes enjoy
your family and know that you are loved
by a lot of people including me
the world is better because of what
you've done and then the former
president says not bad for a skinny poor
kid from searchlight of course those two
had a
good uh relationship there because for
the former president to get anything
done he needed senator reid who was in
control of the majority of senators at
the time which were democrats to get his
agenda done so they really knew each
other quite well and it was harry reid
who got the ball rolling to learn more
about ufos an interesting tidbit there
in 2007 he was the one that started
pressuring the pentagon to study them as
possible real things that of course gave
us more information including those
photos and videos we have come to see
with our george knapp over the years
brian and denise more tributes are
coming in for the former senate majority
leader former nevada governor bob miller
talking to eight news now just a few
minutes ago about his long friendship
with the former senator
it's a sad day for all of us in nevada i
mean
harry has been the most incredible
leader
probably in the history of the state
it's difficult to think of anybody else
that's had a more significant role on a
national level and translated that to
things that were beneficial to nevada
than harry reid
he was one of a kind and and you can't
replace somebody
as gifted as he was
miller says he was motivated to run for
senate by the democratic leader after he
maxed his term as governor now we'll
have much more on the impact reid had in
nevada and the country and so many more
tributes coming up tonight on 8 news now
11.